[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
skimmac consacré au vélo dans 50 ans en
Yvelines vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à utiliser le vélo pour loisirs
pour aller au travail alors on va faire
le point avec Jean-Baptiste amonic qui
vise président en charge des mobilités
pour 50 ans en Yvelines surtout les
efforts qu'ils ont fait pour rendre
l'utilisation de ce vélo plus agréable
plus simple plus facile mais le vélo
c'est aussi le sport vous le savez avec
notamment le Vélodrome et on va tout de
suite rejoindre Laurent Mazery Laurent
Mazoyer vice-président en charge des
sports de 50 ans en Yvelines et il va
nous dresser les listes de toutes les
compétitions qui ont lieu dès maintenant
évidemment jusqu'aux Jeux Olympiques
[Musique]
ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous
allons accueillir dans les mois qui
viennent et dans les années qui viennent
un grand nombre d'épreuves sportifs tout
orienté vers le vélo nous allons bien
évidemment au Vélodrome national
accueillir très prochainement le départ
dans ce site sur ce site de la dernière
épreuve du Tour de France le 23 juillet
prochain le 23 juillet 2023 nous aurons
et c'est dorénavant un rendez-vous
traditionnel au mois de novembre l'UCI
trac championne League au Vélodrome une
soirée entière deux heures de vélo à
haute intensité pour accueillir le plus
grand nombre le départ du Paris-Nice au
mois d'avril et bien évidemment les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 à la fois au
Vélodrome sur le Stadium de BMX sur la
colline d'Élancourt pour le VTT et puis
le passage des deux épreuves de cyclisme
sur route qui traverseront la totalité
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pendant les
Jeux olympiques de 2024
[Musique]
le retour d'expérience est fondamental
pour accueillir des épreuves
internationales ici au Vélodrome nous
avons deux fois de suite accueilli
championnats du monde on a pu tester les
installations et la façon d'écrire les
gens et le 24 septembre prochain sur la
colline Descours tout à côté nous aurons
ce qu'on appelle le festival qui sera
organisé et piloté par Paris 2024 une
vraie fausse compétition avec des vrais
sportifs l'accueil de 5000 spectateurs
donc une jauge inférieure au 12000 qui
sont attendus pour les Jeux olympiques
mais nous testerons à la fois tout ce
qui sera du dispositif de fonctionnement
à l'intérieur du périmètre et nous 50
ans en Yvelines également tout ce qui
touche au transport en commun à la
signalétique à l'accueil des populations
à la façon dont on va utiliser le vélo
pour atteindre le site et à la façon de
tout cela fonctionnera avec les
habitants avec un quartier de la clef de
Saint-Pierre qui continuera à
fonctionner
[Musique]
toutes les installations sont ouvertes
au public on peut faire des stages
d'initiation Vélodrome on peut pratiquer
le vélodrome surpiste ici avec des
champions de l'équipe de France qui vont
vous initier à la pratique du vélo le
VTT demain sera ouvert à tous le BMX les
clubs et nos associations viennent y
faire du BMX tous les jours bref le vélo
c'est tous les jours à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pour tous
[Musique]
bonjour Jean-Baptiste ça va bien
merci de recevoir un chez vous dans
votre mairie avec plaisir
parce que vous êtes le maire de
Villepreux mais vous êtes aussi le
vice-président de 50 ans en charge des
transports des mobilités exactement et
on va donc parler de ce vélo alors viens
de voir avec Laurent mazory les
compétitions c'est très important les
compétitions Vélodrome il y aura la
dernière étape du Tour de France
il y a les JO évidemment il y a eu le
Paridis il y a quelques temps aussi qui
était en rencontre événement vers le
cycliste alors ça c'est pour les
sportifs c'est pour les professionnels
c'est mais il y a aussi tous les jours
des gens qui utilisent le vélo pour leur
loisirs pour aller au boulot qu'est-ce
que vous faites pour eux alors
effectivement on sait que 50 ans en
Yvelines est une terre de vélo pour le
sport pour les loisirs mais demain à la
vocation à être aussi une terre du vélo
pour les déplacements du quotidien et la
raison pour laquelle une des grandes
ambitions de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin c'est de doubler un minima
d'ici 10 ans la part modale que
représente le vélo au sein de l'ensemble
des déplacements 50 chinois et donc on
va mettre sur la table comme on dit un
grand plan d'investissement de 37
millions d'euros sur 10 ans exactement
pour pouvoir créer un réseau qui viendra
mailler l'ensemble du territoire de
l'agglomération et alors ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire des pistes cyclables
ça veut dire ça veut dire effectivement
déjà des infrastructures le plus
important on sait que pour qu'un
itinéraire soit viable et soit utilisé
par les cyclistes il faut qu'il soit
sécurisé et puis il faut éviter les
discontinuités comme donc on va à la
fois créer l'équivalent de 600 km de
piste cyclables alors quand je dis créer
c'est soit créé soit améliorer
l'existence
sur l'agglomération l'ambition c'est
d'arriver à 600 exactement donc c'est de
la voie verte c'est de la piste cyclable
c'est aussi parfois des zones de contre
on utilise à peu près toutes les
infrastructures possibles avec des
différentes réglementations aussi qui
s'offrent à nous pour pouvoir faire que
le vélo trouve toute sa place
aujourd'hui sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et soit
utilisé par le plus grand nombre alors
je dis tout à l'heure sport évidemment
les JO est-ce que ça ça une affluence
justement le sport sur la façon dont
vous concevez peut-être les
infrastructures pour les pour les
utilisateurs de tous les jours oui comme
je disais on sait que l'agglomération
est déjà territoire de vélo grâce au
vélo de Rome grâce à tout ce que tu as
évoqué et donc je pense que on est
quelque part déjà dans le peloton
maintenant il faut qu'on soit dans
l'échappée donc on met un coup
d'accélérateur sur la mais c'est
vrai que de pouvoir bénéficier
d'événements planétaires comme les gens
olympiques comme le Tour de France il y
a déjà cette culture Vélo qui est très
prégnante sur l'agglomération et dans
l'esprit des 50 lois maintenant si on
veut trois fois en mode transformer
l'essai il faut vraiment que on s'appuie
sur cette équipe pour passer vraiment à
automatique à la politique de la
mobilité et à la mobilité douce et
durable et là le vélo constitue un atout
assez formidable un mot sur la sécurité
parce que il y a en effet dans des
villes il y a Paris il y a des accidents
il y a des bas ici il me semble que par
chance enfin peut-être pas par chance
peut-être grâce aux infrastructures
aussi les problèmes de sécurité sont
peut-être moins présents ils sont moins
premium ils sont moins présents parce
que je crois que déjà on a un territoire
plus périurbain Paris c'est très
urbanisé
certes on a le cœur de l'agglomération
la ville nouvelle
espace qu'ici ou à Magny-les-Hameaux
mais néanmoins on a des grandes
infrastructures faut pas oublier aussi
qu'on va s'appuyer sur le réseau du de
la région le rerv qui va venir traverser
l'agglomération avec deux axes la B3 et
la C1 et puis le plan vélo du
département aussi qui vient poser
j'allais dire un maillage complémentaire
sur lequel nous on peut s'appuyer
finalement également les planètes
s'alignent quand on a l'état qui
développe son plan de l'eau la Région
Département l'agglomération et les
communes et tout le monde va pouvoir
faire quelque chose exactement dans le
sens de la course en dans la même
direction vous connaissez évidemment les
ce qu'on sait qu'on appelle les vélos
d'affaires évidemment c'est ceux qui
vont au taf au boulot très présent sur
certains vélos alors justement il y a un
challenge qui s'appelle le challenge
inter-entreprise qui a déjà eu lieu qui
aura lieu cette année le 30 mai et
l'année dernière c'est une entreprise
qui s'appelle geophyte qui est reporté
on a été les voix et on va faire le
point justement sur ce sur ce nouveau
challenge interne entreprise qui aura
lieu donc le 30 mai prochain
[Musique]
50 ans en Yvelines a mis en place le
challenge vélo inter-entreprise pour
développer les trajets domicile travail
à vélo nous avons trois challenges
différents donc nous avons deux
challenges individuels donc le meilleur
rouleur celui qui réalisera le plus de
kilomètres le meilleur cycliste celui
qui réalisera le plus grand nombre de
trajets également la meilleure
entreprise cycliste à savoir le ratio
entre le nombre de trajets et le nombre
total de collaborateurs
[Musique]
on voit les noms qui a en fait ils
participent au Challenge safran Airbus
boule challenger c'est toujours
intéressant de finir amoureux c'est une
petite fierté
[Musique]
je pense que c'est incité aussi la
direction puis le service RSE a
accélérer la mise en place de la Charte
mobilité et depuis le début d'année ils
ont mis en place le forfait mobilité
durable
qui à l'eau d'une petite somme d'argent
pour revenir au travail en vélo
[Musique]
en tant que référente du challenge vélo
au début je me suis inscrite vraiment
pour participer au challenge en tant que
tel tout l'été j'ai fait que des trajets
à vélo et c'est vraiment très
appréciable notamment avec les beaux
jours sur le territoire on a quand même
beaucoup de pistes cyclables sécurisées
entre collègues on se motive pour
participer et c'est assez marrant parce
que du coup il est vraiment un événement
fédérateur autour de ça certaines
entreprises du coup se tirent Labout
entre elles et certains font des trajets
beaucoup plus grands pour entrer chez
eux juste pour avoir plus de kilomètres
que le concurrent de l'autre entreprise
il faut conserver son titre donc on va
faire le maximum pour le conserver cette
année
[Musique]
voilà le vélo taf ça se développe de
plus en plus j'adore ce beau vélo
évidemment
et puis
le service aussi de la location oui
parce que il y a ceux qui bénéficient
d'aide justement pour l'achat de vélo
notamment
en gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Bretonneux la vélocation avec ce qui
sera demain notre agence de la mobilité
qui se réveille en mobile va pouvoir se
déplacer dans les territoires c'est ça
on sera pas obligé d'aller à la gare
forcément
le vélo pourrait être apporté à ceux qui
le réservent donc on a plusieurs
centaines de vélo un vélo des vélos
électriques comme celui-ci des vélos
standards à la location très courte à
plus longue durée pour essayer de et
bien répondre aux besoins qui
s'expriment de la part des cinq
continents donc on peut prendre on prend
aussi des il y a aussi des trottinettes
il y a aussi des trottinettes en
libre-service ça marche très très bien
et on a décidé d'ailleurs pérenniser ce
service pour les prochaines années là
aussi là ici il y a pas il y a pas de de
problème de débat sur l'existence des
cette mobilité non parce qu'on a un
territoire qui s'y prête on a été les
premiers à le faire sur un territoire
périurbain et puis maintenant on voit
qu'un certain nombre d'interconnalités
et communes nous suivent donc c'est très
positif en tout cas on est aujourd'hui à
plusieurs millions de déplacements donc
c'est tant mieux alors on parlait tout à
l'heure justement du vélo sportif du
vélo de loisirs du vélo pour aller
bosser il y a un club qui est un très
ancien club qui est le velux club de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux on les voit
passer même à Villepreux de temps en
temps voilà et alors là il y a de tout
et en effet des gens qui font du sport
il y a aussi des lever le tourisme ils
sont tous dans la même dans la même
association bon on est allé le voir voir
le VCMB le Vélo Club de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
[Musique]
jusqu'au bout de la ligne droite à
l'entrée où il y a le panneau la
bâcheresse le village et là vous arrêtez
on se regroupe tous avant de repartir le
Vélo Club de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
regroupe un peu plus de 500 personnes
soit en loisir soit en compétition qui a
trois sections une section cycle
tourisme loisirs donc route une section
VTT loisirs et la section compétition
qui fait le lien entre les deux c'est
des disciplines qui se complètent
puisque la route ça apporte beaucoup sa
porte de la force du de l'endurance du
foncier le VTT ça apporte de la
technique de l'explosivité par exemple
tous ceux qui font du VTT de niveau ils
font aussi de la route à côté
elle est venue avec son VTT vous voulez
faire des compétitions de VTT
voilà elle a fait de la route elle a
fait du cyclo-cross et elle a découvert
et elle se fait plaisir
en même temps
[Musique]
on a de la chance d'être une équipe de
filles ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui
est très rare dans les dans les clubs en
vélo d'avoir plusieurs filles comme ça
chaque année on a au moins 4 5 ou 6
jeunes qui viennent et qui ont pas de
vélo et nous on essaye de leur louer des
vélos pour prix modique à l'année c'est
un sport populaire et je tiens à ce qui
reste populaire et non pas réservé à une
élite qui a des moyens financiers
[Musique]
Olga qui fait de la compétition il va
traiter je dirais vulgairement les
cyclotourides de Charlot normalement
c'est deux mondes qui s'ignorent voilà
là comme on est dans le même club il y a
plus le même regard
[Musique]
quand on habite Montigny ou
l'agglomération de 51 en Yvelines on est
privilégié on fait 7 km et on n'est plus
en zone urbaine donc c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
presque j'ai l'impression mais je parle
sous votre contrôle que finalement le
vélo on trouve enfin c'était plutôt les
jeunes les sportifs maintenant j'ai
l'impression que ça peut concerner tout
le monde quoi avec le vélo électrique le
vélo musculaire notamment oui quand on
veut faire du vélo une mobilité du
quotidien faut qu'on puisse s'adresser à
un public large et d'ailleurs c'est
aussi pour ça qu'avec les communes on
développe le savoir rouler à vélo parce
que faut aussi apprendre à nos enfants à
faire du vélo donc c'est les jeunes
c'est les plus jeunes et puis c'est les
un peu moins jeunes les plus anciens en
tout cas on fait en sorte que justement
il n'y ait pas que les vélos taffeurs
qui puissent et bien utiliser le vélo
mais l'ensemble des 56 mois quel que
soit leur âge merci beaucoup
Jean-Baptiste
vive le vélo
[Musique]